>> HERE WITH MORE REACTION
DINMONT YOU KNOW ALONG WITH THE
HOST, I WILL SAY THIS TO BOTH O
YOU UPFRONT, YOU WILL BOTH UNDE
NO CIRCUMSTANCES TO I WANT TO
POLITICIZE ANY OF THIS TONIGHT.
FAMILIES MAY NOT EVEN KNOW THE
STATUS OF THEIR OWN CHILDREN AT
THIS HOUR YET WE HAVE THIS
RAISED EVEN BY THE PRESIDENT TO
POLITICIZE IT BY I JUST FIND SO
OFFENSIVE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO KEEP KID
SAFE IN SCHOOL.
DAN, I'VE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
YEARS.
PEOPLE, RETIRED MILITARY, WROTE
WHAT RETIRED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OUTSIDE THE PERIMETER OF EVERY
SCHOOL AND THE COUNTRY, THEY
COULDN'T DONATE THEIR TIME, THE
CAN OFFER THEM TAX BREAKS,
FEDERALLY COVERED TEN HOURS A
WEEK AND WE CAN HAVE EVERY
SCHOOL IN AMERICA COVERED.
PEOPLE AROUND THE PERIMETER,
PEOPLE AND THE HALLS, FIRST
RESPONDERS THERE, WE DON'T HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT POLICE RESPONSE
TIMES.
NOBODY SEEMS TO HAVE HEIGHTENED
THAT HE DIA APPEALING.
I DON'T KNOW ANY OTHER WAY TO
KEEP KIDS SAFE.
>> IT WOULD BE A LOT LESS THAN
WHAT WE'RE GIVING UKRAINE.
>> AND COUPLE OF THINGS GREAT
IT'S TOO LATE TO NOT POLITICIZE
IT.
IT'S NOT YOU DOING IT, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
JUST CAME OUT OF WHAT COULD'VE
BEEN FOR ALL OF US TO MOURN
TOGETHER.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, HE DECIDED TO
ATTACK THE GUN LOBBY.
I WASN'T AWARE THEY GUN LOBBY
WAS INVOLVED IN THE SHOOTING.
AGAIN, HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IN A MOMENT
WHERE HE COULD ABET A HEALER IT
MAY UNIFIER, HE DECIDED THAT
MOMENT WAS A GOOD TIME TO START
YELLING AT AMERICANS.
CUTESY TIME WITH THESE PEOPLE
ARE OVER, THEY DON'T CARE.
ON YOUR SECOND POINT, THIS IS
WHAT I DID FOR A LIVING.
OPERATIONAL SECURITY IN PHYSICA
SECURITY.
PAT WAS A GREAT GUEST.
THE MAN TRAP IS A TERRIFIC IDEA
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET INTO THE
SECOND DOOR IN THE MAN TRAP ONC
THE FIRST DOOR IS CLOSED RIGHT
AND THEY HAVE TO OPERATE THE
SECOND DOOR CABINET MEETING IF
YOU HAVE A GUN THEY'RE GOING TO
TRAP YOU BETWEEN THE TWO DOORS
AND YOU WILL GO ANYWHERE.
I DISAGREE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THE PERSONNEL.
HE'S ACCURATE, IF YOU THINK OF
IT IN TERMS OF ACTIVE POLICE
OFFICERS IN THE UNITED STATES,
YES, WE CAN'T PUT ONE AT EVERY
SINGLE DOOR IN EVERY SCHOOL ALL
THE TIME.
TO PUT YOUR THINKING WHERE I
THINK YOU'RE CORRECT, WE SHOULD
EXPAND THAT FOOTPRINT APPEARED
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF RETIRED LAW
ENFORCEMENT THIRD WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE INPUT PURSUITS
BUT ARE CAPABLE OF SECURING A
TWO OR 3-ACRE SCHOOL SOMEWHERE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO THINK OUTSID
THE BOX.
THE SKILLS ARE THERE IN THE
HUMAN CAPITAL IS THERE.
WE JUST GOT 20 OR $30 BILLION I
SCHOOL FUNDING, HELP PROBABLY
MORE THAN THAT FOR THE COVID
THING.
WE CAN GO OUT AND TAKE CARE OF
THESE SCHOOLS AND SECURE THEM?
WE COULD DO BETTER THAN THAT
PRETTY GET THIS MEAT BE AN AREA
WE CAN ALL HAVE.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
TRAINED COVERT RETIRED POLICE,
RETIRED MILITARY.
YOU KNOW THESE PEOPLE WELL, WHA
IF THEY DONATED TEN OR 15 HOURS
A WEEK AT THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT RIGHT AND WHAT IF WE
SAID OKAY, IF YOU DO THAT WE
WILL GIVE YOU A BREAK IN YOUR
INCOME TAXES YOU DON'T HAVE TO
PAY IT AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO PA
STATE AND LOCAL TAXES EITHER.
IT WOULDN'T EVEN COST US A PENN
IN THE END.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU ABOUT SCHOO
SECURITY, I ALWAYS HAVE.
AS THE GRANDFATHER OF FIVE, THI
ABSOLUTELY MAKES ME SICK TO MY
STOMACH.
I BEGGED THOSE FAMILIES TO
ACCEPT OUR CONDOLENCES, THE
SLAUGHTER HAS BEEN SOMETHING
THAT WE WILL LIVE WITH ALL OF US
, IT IS ABSOLUTELY HORRIBLE
GREAT WHEN YOU THINK OF THOSE
LITTLE BABIES, I COVERED SANDY
HOOK RATE IT IS THAT A AGAIN.
LEAVES LITTLE CHILDREN COME AT
THE MOST VULNERABLE INNOCENT
BEINGS ON EARTH, THEY
SLAUGHTERED.
THE ONLY PLACE YOU, DAN, AND I
DIVERGE IS IT IS NOT TO ME
IRRELEVANT, THAT IN THE LAST TE
DAYS, 30 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KILLE
BY TO 18 -YEAR-OLDS WITH ASSAUL
WEAPONS.
HOW CAN YOU BUY AN ASSAULT
WEAPON ON YOUR 18TH BIRTHDAY
WHEN YOU COULD NOT BUY BEER?
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
IN SPOKEN WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
AGAINST THIS.
WHY NOT HAVE A JUVENILE ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN?
IF YOU CAN'T BUY A BEER, YOU
CAN'T BUY AN ASSAULT WEAPON.
WHY IS THAT UN-AMERICAN?
HOW DOES THAT RELATE TO SECOND
AMENDMENT?
>> WHAT I THINK THE ARGUMENT IS
IN MY THOUGHTS ARE REALLY WITH
THESE FAMILIES ALL INTO YOUR
QUESTION AND TELL YOU IT'S
PREDICATED ON THE FALSE NOTION
THAT EVIL PEOPLE WITH EVIL
INTENT, YOU HAVE TO BE EVIL TO
PERPETRATE AT CRIME AND BY THE
VERY NATURE OF SOMEBODY BEING
THAT EVIL, THEY ARE NOT GOING T
OBEY, THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
LISTEN TO ANY LAWS BECAUSE THAT
IS COMING FROM THEIR HEART IF
YOU'RE HARD TO DRIVE YOU TO DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS, IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT'S LEGAL OR NOT LEGA
IN THEIR WORLD, IT MATTERS IN
YOUR WORLD.
I PAY ON MY TAXES, DAN PAYS ALL
OF HIS.
I OVERPAY JUST TO BE SURE.
BUT IN THIS CASE, YOU'RE ASKING
PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE A HEART
OR A SOUL OR A CONSCIOUS TO OBE
A LOT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO OBEY.
>> WE HAVE TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN WITH THE SAME VIGOR WE
PROTECT THE MONEY IN OUR BANKS.
WHAT'S WORTH MORE, THE MONEY OR
THE CHILDREN?
IF WE CAN PROTECT THE MONEY, WE
SHOULD PROTECT THE CHILDREN.
AN OLD COP, A RETIRED COP,
SOMEBODY.
MILITARY.
ARMED.
ABSOLUTELY ARMED.
GERALDO, WAIT, BECAUSE I WANT T
RESPOND TO YOUR FIRST POINT, YO
ASKED A QUESTION.
OVER A DECADE IN LAW ENFORCEMEN
I ARRESTED A LOT OF PEOPLE, AND
THEY LOVE YOUR IDEA FOR GUN LAW
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHY?
IF NOBODY GIVES A ABOUT GUN LAWS
.
CANNOT ANSWER THE QUESTION?
THIS IS SO HALF WHY IT'S SO HAR
TO COME ON WITH YOU.
I DIDN'T INTERRUPT YOU, MAN.
LISTEN, LET'S JUST BE RESPECTFU
OF EACH OTHER IN THIS REALLY
HARD TIME.
I'M JUST TELLING YOU IN MY
EXPENSE, YES, I DON'T LIKE AN 1
-YEAR-OLD WHO'S INCOMPETENT
POTENTIALLY MENTALLY ILL IN THI
HOMICIDAL MITT ENIAC TO HAVE AN
ASSAULT RIFLE.
WE BOTH AGREE 100 PERCENT.
THOUGHTS AND UNNECESSARILY KIND
OF HOSTILE TERM, THERE IS NO
SUCH THING IS AN ASSAULT WEAPON
BUT HAVING SAID THAT, I'M
TELLING YOU YOU'RE TALKING ABOU
AND OBVIOUSLY PSYCHOLOGICALLY
DISTURBED YOUNG MAN HERE WHO
WALKED INTO A SCHOOL IN SHOT A
BUNCH OF SCHOOLKIDS.
DO YOU REALLY BELIEVE HE WAS
SITTING THEY'RE READING A A LOT
OF BEFORE HAND?
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO SAY
MAYBE WE SHOULD MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO DO THAT, BUT THE
PROBLEM WITH THAT IS IT'S A
SIMPLEMINDED SOLUTION BECAUSE
YOU ALSO MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT
FOR THE TENS AND THOUSANDS AND
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF OTHER
18 -YEAR-OLD OUT THERE THAT HAV
DONE NOTHING WRONG AND WOULD
LIKE TO BUY A RIFLE TO GO
HUNTING.
>> SO WHAT SO WHAT YOU'RE 18
YEARS OLD, CAN YOU BUY A BEER?
ANSWERED NO, WHY CAN'T YOU BUY
BEER?
BECAUSE SOCIETY IN IF
INSUFFICIENT WISDOM HAS DECIDED
YOU CAN'T.
>> MY QUESTION REMAINS.
>> WHY DO YOU BELIEVE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE NO CONSCIENCE, NO
HEART, AND NO SOUL, PARENTS LOS
THEIR KIDS TODAY, WHY DO YOU
BELIEVE--WHY DO YOU BELIEVE IN
ANY WAY THAT THOSE PEOPLE ARE
CAPABLE OF THAT EVIL ARE GOING
TO OBEY YOUR LAWS?
I THINK YOU'RE LIVING IN A
FANTASY WORLD.
>> MAY BE I AM, BUT THE NRA
CONVENTION IF YOUR PRESIDENT
TRUMKA ME HAVE GOVERNOR ABBOTT,
ABSENT RECRUITS ALL SCHEDULED T
SPEAK GREAT DON'T YOU THINK YOU
SHOULD TRY TO SUGGEST SOME
REMEDY, PROACTIVE.
WHAT THEY GOING TO DO?
>> THE WAY THE SECOND AMENDMENT
IS CONSTRUED THERE MAKES ME SICK
.
HOW DID BECOME A CASE.
>> WAIT, HOLD ON.
YOU DOMINATED THIS WHOLE
CONVERSATION.
AND ON ANYBODY ELSE TALKING.
THE LAST 30 YEARS OF YOUR LIFE,
EVENT OF WEALTHY SUCCESSFUL GUY
NOBODY DISPUTES THAT.
YOU CAN GO OUT TOMORROW ENDED B
SECURITY IF YOU WANT TOO.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT MAKES YOU
SICK?
THE CRIMINALS DON'T CARE ABOUT
YOUR GUN LAWS, IT KEEPS
LAW-ABIDING PEOPLE AND ARMS
WHILE THEY DON'T GIVE A ABOUT
YOUR LAWS.
I DID THIS FOR A LIVING.
THEY LAUGH AT GUN LAWS AND THEY
LOVE PEOPLE LIKE YOU ADVOCATING
FOR GUN LAWS BECAUSE YOU CAN BU
ARMED PROTECTION AND THEY CAN G
IN HIGH CRIME COMMUNITIES AND
PRAY ON INNOCENT PEOP